et là on est en train de faire le
mondial
[Musique]
je vais aller au tour et je masque par
contre ce que je vous demande ce qui est
important c'est pas net de crème
pâtissière sur le dessous vous nous
préparez ça je vais préparer le fondant
pour faire le décor
[Musique]
on est une institution depuis plus de
100 ans donc on a beaucoup de
connaissances qu'on connaît bien les
métiers donc on va apporter notre
expertise à la cité et la cité aussi
nous apporter son rayonnement au grand
public et à l'international pour
découvrir la gastronomie française
[Musique]
et
la gastronomie c'est mondiale et donc on
veut montrer cela avec nos spécificités
et nos produits typiques de la région
mais c'est pas du tout quelque chose de
localisme ou lecalier c'est quelque
chose toute la sphère internationale
d'ailleurs ça s'appelle csgv cité
internationale de la gastronomie et du
vin
[Musique]